- L'École de l'Étincelle
scolaires vétustes du Québec,
cotés "D" ou "E".
Ses problèmes de fenêtres,
de plomberie et d'infestation de
souris font partie du quotid
AMÉLIE CAYOUETTE, enseignante,
École de l'Étincelle,
- Moi, c'est arrivé cette année,
j'avais trouvé un de mes élèves
ouvert dans les mains.
reusement, il y a eu
rien de grave qui est arrivé.
de cette école spécialisée,
accueillant des élèves âgés
entre 4 et 12 ans ayant
l'autisme, pourront déménagerdat
en 2028.
Entre-temps, une relocalisation
pour ces jeunes, qui peinent
à cohabiter avec les travaux.
- Nos élèves, ils sont
hypersensibles au bruit,
les comportements d'agression
augmentent, d'automutilation
t'sais, ils ne sont vraiment pas
bien quand il y a des situations
- L'école Sophie-Barat,
également cotée "Eplus
vieille du Centre de services
scolaire de Montréal.
projet de rénovation et
d'agrandissement.
Le gouvernement du Québec
y a versé 164 millions $, mais
en branle.
SABRINA GUADAGNANO, mère d'élève
école secondaire Sophie-Barat
jamais, puis je pense que
les parents dans le quartier
Ahuntsic sont un peu découragés.
est en train de rater sa cible,
qu'il avait pourta
la peine d'abaisser fortement
en cours de mandat.
de l'Éducation du Québec
- L'objectif est d'obtenir,'obt,
d'améliorer les choses pour
qu'en 22-23, on ait au moins
classé "A", "B" ou "C".
On voudrter ça
bien plus vite, mais on part
de tellement loin!
et secondaires du Québec ont été
construites entre 1950 et 1970.
dégradation est inévitable.
JEAN-PASCAL FOUCAULT, professeur
- Je n'estime pas plutôt que
dans les années à venir, on va
par une baguette magique.
C'est un investissement d'au
société.
- D'ici là, c'est tout le milieu
la rentrée avec appréhension.
- Ça fait que ça, c'est sûr que
ça nous stresse beaucoup,,
ça me stresse, oui.
- Ici, Gabriel Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Montréal